[Music]
hey what's going on YouTube
let's talk about something real quick
now my videos have been a little bit
splotchy lately because I've been a bit
busy and when I say I'm a bit busy this
is what I mean by it this is going to be
kind of a heart-to-heart talk and I kind
of want to connect with y'all on this
and we're just going to have a
conversation so when I started YouTube I
didn't expect myself to be on YouTube
this long I thought that I was going to
be on YouTube for a couple years my
stand-up comedy career was going to pop
up and got a comedy when the only thing
I ever wanted to do I still do stand-up
till this day but I just don't have a
fire for it it's not because I
personally think I suck at it or I don't
have any talent in it it doesn't make me
happy like it used to and content
creating good in the past year I've
worked on a really really big project
that kind of really fulfilled a huge
piece of my heart and that project was
boob the film and the reason why I
wanted to do goop the film and start you
know developing that project was just in
and help reduce it and then be a lead in
the movie was because here's the thing I
talked big you guys have seen me on this
channel talk about you know Asian
American content or whatever whatnot but
but the problem with that is that if you
top the top you better [ __ ] walk the
walk a lot of people on the internet
like to talk about Asian entertainment
about what's going on in Hollywood and
what things should be done but number
one they don't support the films that
are out there doing it number two
they're not creating the films that are
supposed to make noise and number three
they know nothing about it but they want
to talk the biggest about me I just
didn't want to fall in that category so
with Justin when he allowed me to be a
part of this project I wanted to make
sure that our voice was heard not this
type of film where it says like we're
asian-american and this is what we were
about being big I think those are the
worst type of films especially when it
comes to Asian American films work in
the dialogue it says but we're Asian and
this is what we have to do no we wanted
to create a film that kind of lived in
his characters and you guys took what
you want from it it wasn't an
asian-american film it was an amazing
film that had an asian-american
background to it that's it but moving on
from that this year one of the biggest
reasons why I have been so quote-unquote
distracted or
focus is because I'm starting to go into
acting acting is one of those huge
amount of things that have a respect for
now this is what acting has kind of done
for me or going into these auditions and
I don't know if I'm gonna get a part or
not but I'm in a weird space right now
where me going into acting I look at
myself in when I go to these auditions
and I say dude you [ __ ] suck and you
know what the cool thing about sucking
at something is it shows that there is
room for you to grow and for me that's
[ __ ] exciting I've been on YouTube
now for the past six years and you know
after you hit a million subscribers the
only thing that keeps me doing this is
you guys like me making content for you
and then making you laugh and having
this conversation they give you buy
something to watch that's not mindless
drivel but for me as a challenge I need
to do something where I can look at
myself but they do that look at where
you're at you [ __ ] suck you're
garbage
now how can you get better and the
reason why I do that and this is
something very personal I'll share with
you guys one of my biggest fears is
waking up without a purpose that was a
point of my life where I remember I
couldn't find a reason to open my eyes
and for me that was hard not in the
sense that I wanted to [ __ ] kill
myself but it was more along the lines
of if you wake up without a purpose
what's the whole point of continuing
your day what do you do throughout the
day when you wake up without a purpose
the only thing you're waiting for is for
it to become night again so you could
sleep and that was difficult for me and
I felt like that once for about a whole
year and this was before I decided to go
in the stand-up comedy and music and
everything else when I decided to go
ahead and become a stand-up comedian it
gave me real purpose it helped me feel
alive and for me now after group the
film ended I kind of started feeling
that again what is my purpose I'm not
saying that YouTube is just something
that I won't stop doing what I'm saying
is that I need something a little bit
more in terms of like goals I had that
feeling of waking up and not feeling
challenged not feeling that
I had a purpose in life again and it
scared the [ __ ] [ __ ] at me like diet
woke up and I couldn't find a reason to
get out of bed it was it's weird like I
don't know if you guys ever felt that I
don't know if that's something that you
guys can even relate to but I have a
feeling that at a certain point you're
like you will feel that way and that to
me is scary is [ __ ] it makes me not
want to wake up I don't know what else
to explain it but when I started talking
to a lot of my friends in terms of like
acting and I had to look at myself and a
lot of people said like how come you
haven't tried acting them you do it all
the time you worked on a film that got
into Sundance it won the next audience
award don't you think you have something
to offer and I had to take a good look
at myself and I realized something the
reason why I haven't even gone into
acting in the first place because I was
scared I was scared that when I walked
into an audition room that these people
who judge what I do would validate that
I don't have talent that I'm scaleless
but the only reason why I got to where
I'm at now was because of luck and you
know and I know I shouldn't feel that
way because you know Sundance was a big
deal and I just put in a minute I would
always have an excuse like oh it's not
something I want to do right now I have
so many other goals which I did but a
big part of it was fear and then I
realized that that fear and feeling that
was a purpose for me it was something
that made me feel alive if you really
want to do something like if it's like
burning inside of you like you had that
type of passion and you suck at it don't
take that as something as it something
that's going to defeat you let that be
your motivation what it absolutely shows
is that you are at the bottom right now
but all that means is that everything
above you is just room to grow you guys
are going to be going on this journey
with me me wanting to become an actor
and show you know Hollywood that I got
something but I'm not justice guys were
just talking to a camera issues a few
sketches I had something to offer I you
know this is kind of bold because what
if I [ __ ] fail what if I fail I fail
I'll learn from it you know I'll work
out you know with these or something but
I kind of wanted to make this video
because even if you're new to this
channel there are certain people
that has been with me since day one
since like six five six years ago and
you guys have seen me grown into
something different you guys must see me
for making these stupid little videos at
home all the way to making a feature
film so weird that you guys had been
able to share every [ __ ] step of the
way with me and thank you like I
appreciate it so much I don't know if
I'm going to be successful I don't know
if anything good is going to come of
this what I do know is that I'm going to
try my best and if I fail you guys will
be there to see it and you guys will
also be there to see my successes I'll
still be making content every Sunday I
will try my best but if I don't because
I'm auditioning I'm working on my acting
but other than that thank you let's uh
let's get it baby hey what is going on
YouTube um just to say thank you once
again I don't know if I'll be lifelong
in the whole situation but I'll be
creating new content all the time I
don't know what the [ __ ] I'm going to be
creating but it may not be in this room
it may be some random [ __ ] who [ __ ]
knows but at the end of the day thank
you guys and I just wanted to update you
on this because it's important to the
side note if a few you guys see me out
in public you want to say hi and just
say hi don't do this thing where you're
in the corner you go a hundred percent
will not [ __ ] turn around absolutely
not
you guys have to say my name come up to
me I'll give you a hug
I'll kiss you on the [ __ ] mouth if
you want to goddammit love you